- Hello.
Welcome to "The Benjamin and
Barbara Zucker Lecture Series"
at Yale's Program for the
Study of Antisemitism.
My name is Alice Kaplan.
I'm the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center
and a member of the
Advisory Board of YPSA.
I'm delighted to welcome Julia
Elsky, Associate Professor
in the Department of Modern
Languages and Literatures
at Loyola University Chicago.
It's a special pleasure to
welcome Julia back to Yale.
She completed her Ph.D. in French in 2014,
and since then, her
accomplishments in the twin areas
of Jewish studies and French
studies have been remarkable.
In 2020, she published
"Writing Occupation:
Jewish Emigre Voices in Wartime France"
with Stanford University Press's series
on Jewish history and culture,
and you'll see a link
to the book under chats.
This book studies how Jewish
emigre writers re-examined
both their Jewishness
and their place as authors
writing and publishing or not publishing
in France during the occupation.
Her talk this afternoon
is drawn, in large part,
from research conducted
at the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum.
Julia has published articles
on World War II and its legacy
as well as on Jewish identity in France
in "PMLA," "Yale French Studies,"
"La Nouvelle Revue
francaise," "Archives juives,"
and other journals.
She's the recipient of
grants and fellowships
too numerous to name.
She's contributed
to the Holocaust Museum's
digital collection
of objects of memory
called "Experiencing History."
We're also putting that on the chat.
It's really a fascinating
digital experience,
clicking on that link.
Please, keep an eye out for
two of her current projects,
both of them co-authored,
one called "Undesirables in France:
German-Jewish Women,
Artists, and intellectuals
during the Holocaust"
and, still in the planning
stages, a museum exhibit
on the flight of the avant-garde
through wartime Marseille.
And finally, Julia Elsky's
new book project is
about the origins of the
theater of the absurd
during the Second World War
with a focus on Ionesco's inner
war and wartime experiences.
Today, she will speak to us
about a Jewish poetics of
exile, Benjamin Fondane,
and Jewish emigre authors
in occupied France.
Please, submit questions,
as we go, in the Q and A.
Julia will speak for about 40 minutes.
And then, we'll open it up for discussion.
- Hello, I hope this is working now
with me speaking (laughs).
I would like to thank
YPSA for inviting me,
especially Alice Kaplan
and Maurie Samuels.
It's really a true honor to speak at Yale,
where I did my Ph.D. in French
and where I began the project
from which I'm drawing my
research for my talk today
with the generous guidance of Alice Kaplan
and much support from Maurice Samuels.
And this work would really not be possible
without your intellectual and
personal generosity, Alice.
In my talk today,
I will first discuss
the historical context
of Jewish Eastern European
immigrants to France
in the interwar period
and then their experiences
under the Nazi occupation of France.
I'll then turn to the question
of how two Jewish writers
changed their approaches
to writing in French
in response to the persecution
of the Jews in France.
The title of my talk focused on Fondane,
but actually, I really should've said
it's about Fondane and one
other writer, Jean Malaquais.
First, I'll talk
about the Polish-born
novelist Jean Malaquais
to think about the question of
anti-Semitic representations
of Jewish voice and speech.
And then, second, I will address
the Romanian-born poet and
philosopher Benjamin Fondane
and his representation of a sense of exile
under the occupation.
One of the main points
that I wanna make today
is that Jewish immigrant
writers did not stop thinking
about their place in France
and as French writers at the
moment of the June 1940 defeat.
The start of the occupation
did not usher in their silence.
In fact, this period has
often been overlooked
in studies of European Francophonie
and even in studies of
Jewish writers in France.
And by European Francophonie,
I'm referring to
non-French European writers
who wrote in French,
whether or not they immigrated to France.
But I argue that the
period of the occupation
is a crucial period of study,
and it was precisely under the occupation
that these authors addressed
the choice to write in French
and faced anti-Semitism in new ways.
Jean Malaquais and Benjamin
Fondane were among a number
of writers who came to
France in their teens and 20s
in the interwar period,
and I wanna share...
Sorry. These are some of
the writers I've studied.
They came to France and
mostly settled in Paris
to become French writers in a country
that represented universalism
and Jewish civil rights.
They also wanted to be part
of a major literary center.
The period after World War I
saw the largest wave of Jewish immigration
in French history,
one that radically
transformed the landscape
of French Jewry,
and I have some facts and figures here.
But by 1940,
of approximately 330,000 Jews in France,
140,000 were immigrants
without French citizenship,
and 55,000 were naturalized.
And you could see, by 1926,
6% of the population of France
were immigrants, Jewish and non-Jewish.
And I noted an important
law, from August 10th, 1927,
that eased requirements
for naturalization,
and this will become important
again under the occupation.
I'll now give a little bit of context
about the experience of the
occupation by Jewish immigrants
from Eastern Europe, in particular,
and focusing on two aspects:
the June 1940 civilian flight from Paris;
the lights just went off here, I'm sorry;
well, okay, they turned back on;
sorry, focusing on the June
1940 civilian flight from Paris,
called the Exode or Exodus,
and then life under the occupation,
living with the threat of
arrest and deportation.
In June 1940,
just before the German
forces entered Paris
and just before France signed an armistice
that divided the country in half,
into a southern and a northern zone,
there was a massive
civilian flight southward,
called the Exode, as I mentioned.
Paris's population dropped
from almost three million people
to between 700,000 and one million people.
In a matter of weeks, the
major city was emptied.
Scholars estimate that the
roads of France were flooded
with around six million people,
or 1/6 of the population, the country,
and two million Belgians
and Luxembourgers.
Irene Nemirovsky famously
depicted this flight
in her novel "Suite francaise"
that was rediscovered
in the early 2000s,
and Benjamin Fondane also represented it.
Emigre authors were in a
unique position in June 1940,
as they were fleeing in a country
to which they had immigrated.
Shannon Fogg has written extensively
about how the Exodus forced
people to rely even more
on individual social structures
and networks for survival,
and emigre writers, indeed, often relied
on their intellectual networks.
And this was not always possible
for other Jewish emigres in France.
As people doubly displaced from home,
emigre writers were particularly in tune
with the notion of exile,
and this perhaps explains why
they wrote, during the war,
about the events of June 1940
in far greater numbers than
their French-born colleagues.
Aside from emigre
authors' fictional texts,
there are surprisingly few
literary depictions of the Exodus
that were written during the war,
although there do exist
many journalistic accounts.
Whether in the occupied or southern zones,
Jewish immigrants were subject
to anti-Semitic and xenophobic legislation
and were threatened with
internment and deportation.
As historian Patrick Weil argues,
there was no clear division
between anti-Semitic and xenophobic laws
under the occupation.
Rather, they were interwoven
and even competed with each other.
From the beginning of the occupation,
the vulnerable status of Jewish refugees
and recently naturalized
Jewish-French citizens
was at the center of legal
changes and government action.
The law of August 10th, 1927,
that, I mentioned earlier, eased
requirements for naturalization
was used as a negative symbol
of the supposed degradation of France,
and it became a vehicle
for denying immigrants
the right to belong as French citizens.
Over 15,000 French people
were denaturalized,
and 110,000 Algerian Jews
lost their citizenship.
Vichy passed anti-Semitic Jewish statutes
in October 1940 and June 1941.
And I indicate toward
the bottom of this slide,
a day after the first Jewish statutes,
(indistinct) law was passed
that allowed for the
internment of foreign Jews.
After the defeat, foreign
Jews were the first
to be rounded up in Paris
in the spring and summer of 1941.
Approximately 3,000 foreign-born Jews died
in French internment camps
early in the occupation.
With the collaboration of Vichy,
Jewish foreign refugees
in French internment camps
were deported eastward
in the first convoys from the
southern zone in August 1942
to concentration camps.
I'm giving these numbers just to indicate
that they were often the first wave
of victims of deportations.
The very tragically
famous Vel d'Hiv roundup
of July 1942
targeted almost 30,000 people
who were stateless or
unnaturalized Jewish immigrants
from Germany, Austria,
Poland, Czechoslovakia,
and the Soviet Union.
By the end of the war,
only 3% of Jewish people
deported from France returned.
75% of Jews in France survived.
And this is a number
that's often in the news,
and it's important to think about
and also to be careful about it.
But when you break it down,
90% of French Jews survived,
compared to 60% of foreign Jews.
I'm gonna stop sharing for a moment,
even though I'll share again.
Under the occupation,
numerous Jewish immigrant authors
responded to anti-Semitism
in new ways,
especially with regard
to the French language.
These authors conceived
of their position as Jewish immigrants
through writing itself during the war,
and just as they were rejected from France
as immigrants and as Jews,
or in reaction to this double rejection
as immigrants and as Jews.
Why do I focus on the
question of French language?
First, the language question is imbricated
in the politics of
assimilation and integration,
including in citizenship law
and across the political spectrum.
This was the case during
the interwar period
and under Vichy.
In the interwar period, as
Nick Underwood has shown
in his exciting new book, "Yiddish Paris,"
French language lessons
were an important part
of the cultural activities
of Yiddish organizations.
Looking at the topic of
language and integration
from a totally different angle,
the demographer Georges
Mauco published a study
of immigration in France in 1932
based on racial classifications.
The scholar Patrick Weil,
who I mentioned earlier,
has done a lot of work on Mauco.
Mauco; that's M-A-U-C-O;
refers to language
as one of the main, or the
major, factors of assimilation.
He argues, based on a so-called fact,
that Slavic immigrants cannot
master the French language,
which is obviously not true,
but his argument is that.
He argues that they are
never going to be able
to assimilate, and his
conclusions were actually accepted
on the left and on the far right
during the interwar period.
Mauco would be considered
one of the major specialists
on immigration under Vichy
when he wrote anti-Semitic texts.
One month after the
start of the occupation,
the Ministry of Justice sought
to create a new nationality code,
and in this code, a criteria would be
speaking and understanding French.
And it should be noted
that Vichy never succeeded
in creating their new nationality code.
The second reason for focusing on language
is that many Jewish
emigre writers responded
in their literature and
in their writing in French
to a specific current
in the xenophobic press of the far right.
The far right featured
anti-Semitic and
xenophobic representations
of Jewish language and accent
as the evidence of the impossibility
of including Jews and Jewish
immigrants in the nation.
This attitude goes back
to "La France juive," or "Jewish France,"
written by the journalist
Edouard Drumont in 1886,
and it continues in the occupation.
A foundational text of
French anti-Semitism
in the 19th century,
Drumont's "La France juive" declares
that Jews cannot really speak French,
because they cannot truly
think like French people.
Drumont even claims that one
can recognize a Jewish person
from their pronunciation
and their accent in French.
Drumont, I'm using his terms.
He says there's no difference
between an Alsatian Jew
and an immigrant from the Levant.
A particularly interesting example
of an article from the occupation
draws on Jewish language
among refugees in Marseille.
And as I mentioned,
there's this major civilian
flight from Paris southward,
and Marseille became a new center
of intellectual life during the war.
French and refugee
artists from around Europe
congregated there as they
waited for visas to leave.
And I'm excited to be working more
on this aspect of Marseille's history
with my colleague Alyssa Shapiro.
From the viewpoint of the far right,
the panorama of accents
in 1940s Marseille...
There's lot of writing
about the cafes that resound
with the accents of refugees.
You find that representation
both among refugees themselves
and in the far right.
But from the point of
view of the far right,
these accents that you could hear
were the sign of racial
corruption of the French city.
Let me share again.
'Kay, the anti-Semitic
collaborationist writer
Lucien Rebatet describes the city
in his article "Marseille la
juive," or "Marseille the Jew,"
which he published
in the collaborationist
newspaper "Je suis partout."
Marseille appeared to him to be dominated
by Jewish immigrants from
Eastern and central Europe.
One of the defining features
of the new Jewish presence
is their language,
and Rebatet generalizes it as Yiddish,
which isn't necessarily the case,
but the way he writes about
it is that it's all Yiddish.
And for Rebatet,
Jewish language is a violent assault
on the calm evenings of the terrace,
of the cafe (speaks in French),
and I have some quotes here:
"Cocktail hour is now Jew hour".
When he hears a Jewish person talking,
he says, "He spits out
some words in Yiddish."
As for other Jewish people
frequenting the cafes,
he writes, "Yiddish
explodes on their tongues.
Their claw-like hands wave
around as high as their ears."
Rebatet writes that the Polish
and Czech Jews in the cafes
seem to be conventional
but far from virile,
in his representation,
middle-aged Bourgeois men,
but their language gives them away.
He says, "They're comfortably
bourgeois in their gray suits
but, with their sinister
mugs of featherless owls,
largely past their 50s,
gibbering in their vile Yiddish,
which resembles German mangled by a sidi."
So not only does Rebatet
single out Jewish difference.
It's a really interesting quote.
He conflates the Jew and the Arab.
Sidi is a derogatory
term for a North African,
an appropriation of the Arab honorific.
So the Jew is like an Arab
trying to speak German.
As Sandrine Sanos writes in her book,
"The Aesthetics of Hate:
Far-Right Intellectuals,
Anti-Semitism, and Gender"
in 1930s France,
and I'm quoting from her,
"Colonial racism and anti-Semitism
were imbricated, rather than parallel,
in this far-right discourse.
Rebatet's article is,
in fact, a prime example
of what Sanos describes
as 'Je suis partout's'
approach in the 1930s
that"; again, I'm quoting her; "promoted
a racialized Frenchness
whose boundaries were mapped
through the simultaneous
and necessary subjection
of colonized subjects
abroad in the empire,
which allowed the denunciation
and verbal persecution
of French Jews within the nation."
And these boundaries of the
French nation were conceived of
in terms of anxieties about masculinity
and the exclusion based on
racial and sexual difference.
In his article on Marseille,
Rebatet hears the male
Jewish refugee accents,
or what he reduces to Yiddish accents,
on the cafe (speaks in
French) of Marseille
as a threat to the
boundaries of pure French
and thus of a nation
whose greatness must be
upheld through empire.
It is a sign
of an unchangeable and
inassimilable Jewish otherness,
and in the context of the war,
I wanna mention that accents
are particularly fraught;
for example, speaking in
what would be thought of
as a foreign Jewish accent
would expose you as a refugee
and thus expose you to
the threat of deportation.
Racist and xenophobic
ideas about Jewish accents
were not new to the
period of the occupation.
Sander Gilman argues that the stereotype
of, quote, "The Jew who
sounds Jewish," or too Jewish,
stands for the Jew who
unmasks himself or herself
as, quote, "possessing all languages
or no language of his or her own
and, as such, is inherently
different and corrupt."
In a xenophobic and anti-Semitic
book published in 1939,
"La grande invasion,"
the author, Saint-Germain,
entitles a chapter
"Le 'bedide gommerze'"
as I note here on the PowerPoint.
This chapter's about how Jews
and foreigners are taking over
small shops in France,
and this title is a
caricature of Jewish voice.
This is like the way, in
French, you have this mocking
of the Jewish voice,
and we see the same, the B
and the G, in other texts,
including in Balzac's novels
as Maurice Samuels has written about.
And it's important to think
about these continuities
in the discourses of Jewish
voice and anti-Semitism
and anti-Semitic
representations of Jewish voice
to take into account how
the writers respond to this
in the interwar period and during the war,
because I don't wanna just bracket off
the years of the occupation, 1940 to 1944,
as if it's this closed-off time.
But it's, rather, part
of a continuous time
in the lives of these writers.
I'll finally get to Jean Malaquais,
and I'll maybe stop sharing
my screen for a moment.
Jean Malaquais is the pen
name of Wladimir Malacki,
a Polish-born novelist
who came to France in the 1920s.
While he was working as a stock boy
in Les Halles, the food halls,
he began to write,
and under Andre Gide's mentorship,
he wrote "Les javanaise,"
which is translated as
"The Men from Nowhere,"
about miners in France,
miners as in people
who work in mines, E-R.
He won the 1939 Prix Renaudot
literary award for this novel,
and after the French
defeat, Malaquais fled
to the southern zone.
He survived with the help
of writers and editors
who were now based in the south of France.
And eventually, he moved to Marseille
and joined its world of
intellectual refugees.
During the war, he began to engage
with the idea of Jewish
language and Jewish characters
in his novel "Planete sans
visa," or "World without Visa."
And so this is an example
of a shift in writing.
He really begins to write about
Jewish voice during the war.
He wrote "World without Visa"
over the course of five years,
from 1942, while he was waiting
for a visa in Marseille,
to 1947, when he was living in Mexico.
And he was able to get out of France
with the aid Varian Fry's famous
emergency rescue committee.
His novel presents a world of refugees
in the tense atmosphere
of Marseille under Vichy rule
prior to the Nazi invasion
of the southern zone
in November 1942.
In "World without Visa's"
multilingual society of refugees,
Malaquais reclaims and
valorizes what was mocked
in the anti-Semitic press,
both the use of Yiddish
and Jewish refugee accents
as I showed in the article
"Marseille la juive."
Malaquais's wartime diaries indicate
that even when he was in Mexico,
he was consulting "Je suis partout,"
the newspaper that published
Lucien Rebatet's article,
and it's reasonable to
conclude that he was familiar
with this kind of discourse.
The first third of Malaquais's
almost-700-page novel
recounts the increasingly tense days
leading up to a large
roundup of Jews in Marseille,
culminating in the arrest
of the Krantz family,
so it's a group of
characters in the novel.
And in crucial scenes,
Malaquais draws out the
anxieties and emotions
of Jewish language
in direct opposition to its
portrayal by the far right
as racial contamination of France.
And here I'm gonna talk
about an example of Yiddish
in the text.
The reader first encounters
the characters Pawel and Sonia Krantz,
who are Jewish refugees from Poland,
on the day before their arrest.
They're in conversation
with Gustave Henri Hirsch,
or Hirsch in English.
Hirsch is a French Jew who
has lost a son in Dunkirk,
and another son has been
taken prisoner by the Nazis.
His father is interned in the
Drancy camp, outside of Paris,
and he now sees himself as the last
of the line of the French Hirsches.
The narrator specifies
that this group was speaking in French,
which is the only language
that Hirsch understands,
but the conversation
unexpectedly turns to Yiddish,
and it reveals anxieties
about Jewish bilingualism,
in this case, bilingualism of
Yiddish and another language.
Sonia Krantz's hold on her
sanity has been slipping
over the course of the conversation,
as she fears the worst for her family.
And as the group is discussing
exit strategies and visas,
Hirsch begins to laugh hysterically,
and Sonia yells in his face and screams
that she wants to know what he
knows and isn't telling her.
And amid all the anger
and the tension and fear
and Hirsch's laughter, they kiss.
And Pawel, her husband, begins to curse,
first in Polish, then in
German, then in Yiddish,
and the Yiddish is actually represented
in the text, interestingly,
in French, not in Yiddish,
but he's supposed to be speaking Yiddish,
so it's an interesting
thing that happens here.
And I have a couple of examples:
"A black year in yourguts."
And that's not a typo.
In the text, the words
are all linked together.
This is Pawel speaking at first.
And then, this scene
then indicates anxieties
about Yiddish speech during the war
because Hirsch is provoked by
Pawel's outburst in Yiddish,
and he says he hears him
muttering his revolting incantations.
Pawel is intoning psalms,
and we find this long
reflection by Hirsch.
It's actually free indirect discourse,
so it's as if the narrator
is in the mind of Hirsch.
And I'll read it: "It was
because of him," him being Pawel.
So Hirsch is thinking about
Pawel's use of Yiddish:
"It was because of him that
France was no longer France,
and life, no longer fit to be to live.
Hirsch was not an anti-Semite.
How could he be, feeling
so little that he was a Jew
so not at all Jewish?"
And Hirsch keeps telling himself
that he cannot be anti-Semitic.
He obviously hates anti-Semites.
And yet the sight of these
Eastern European Jews
fills him with rage.
He says, other than in
reference to the Dreyfus affair,
he'd never heard the word
juive, or Jew, in France
until Eastern European Jews came in.
Hirsch doesn't understand Yiddish,
but just hearing it does something to him,
and what begins as this
terrible condemnation;
he goes on and on;
of Eastern European immigrant Jews
ends with sympathy and love;
for Hirsch soon sees that
he doesn't believe any
of the horrible things he's
thinking of the immigrants,
and he realizes he's just
scared out of his mind.
But this Yiddish
and his perception of
its rhythm of incantation
brings out his own anxieties
about his rejection from
French life as a Jew.
Hirsch gives voice to the fear in response
to anti-Semitic representations
of Jewish language
as the central theme of their
exclusion from the nation.
Another example is
thinking about accent.
I spoke about Yiddish in the book
and now like to think
about how Malaquais responds to accents
in the anti-Semitic press,
and I would say it's a form
of reappropriation or
reclaiming these accents.
He uses the same belittled speech
but now against racial
discourse about accents.
We have another character,
named Raya Bergmann.
You see in the first
line she's thinking...
She just had a dental procedure.
She's Jewish.
We know that, and she's
had a dental procedure,
and she is just speaking
with S's and Z's and sh's.
I'm giving you the, (coughs)
excuse me, English translation.
Sorry, need water.
But the French would be B's and D's.
And so it's a joke because
she had a dental procedure,
and that's why she's speaking in the way
that you would normally associate
with the stereotypes of Jewish voice,
but actually, Malaquais revised the novel,
which was originally published in 1947.
He revised it in the '90s,
right before he died,
for a republication,
and he changed the scene
so that we first meet Raya
and she's just speaking
in this accent that would normally seem
like the stereotypical Jewish accent.
And I provided the quotes here.
And then, as it goes on, you realize
she's only speaking that way
because she had a dental procedure.
The dentist said that her good
old diction would come back,
and you think, "Oh, she
probably doesn't have
what this French dentist would think of
as good Jewish diction."
But then, you learn more about her,
and you realize that she's
actually from Brittany.
And so in this scene,
Malaquais is playing with our assumptions
or breaking our assumptions
of Jewish accent
to make a kind of joke about it here,
and he's disrupting a category
that, at the time, left
no room for disruption.
He's doing this in the face
of anti-Semitic writings
in which language cannot surprise us
but instead is supposed to
be a defining aspect of race.
These are just some
examples I'm giving you
of how Malaquais takes
anti-Semitic discourse
about Jewish speech
and turns it on its head.
I'd like to finally go to
another author, Benjamin Fondane.
There's a great photograph by Man Ray
that I wanted to share.
And I wanna look at his portrayal
of displacement and exile
under the fear of arrest and
the threat of deportation.
Fondane was a Romanian-born
poet and philosopher
who immigrated to France in 1923.
He was already an active member
of the Romanian literary
avant-garde in Bucharest
before he emigrated.
He became a French citizen in 1938
and was mobilized into the French infantry
and served in what has
been called the Phony War.
He was taken prisoner by the
Nazis in the Loire region
in June 1940, just a few
days before the armistice.
After he escaped,
he found himself on the roads in France
during the civilian flight
that I described before.
And then, he was hospitalized
in the Val-de-Grace
military hospital in Paris
for appendicitis.
He spent the occupation living
in semi hiding in Paris,
where he refused to wear the yellow star,
and he continued to write, for a time,
in the literary journal "Cahiers du sud,"
which was based in Marseille
and which helped him out
when he needed to find a
place to live in Marseille.
And I wanted to share a
really amazing postcard
that he wrote to Jean Ballard,
who was the editor of "Cahiers du sud."
He wrote this in October 1940,
and on the postcard, he
expressed his intention
to continue publishing.
Ballard was actually instrumental
in helping to get Fondane
citizenship before the war,
and Fondane turns this
postcard into a creative text.
It's the censored wartime card
with simple fill-in-the-blank
lines used by soldiers
to communicate briefly about their welfare
with their families.
But early on, you can
see (speaks in French),
so you're supposed to be speaking about...
These words mean killed,
prisoner, deceased,
and here Fondane turns
it into a different text,
and he says, (speaks in French)
so "If 'Le Cahiers du
sud' have not been killed,
I remain their prisoner;
philosophy, not deceased."
So Fondane bends the censored
rigid words on the postcard
into a literary text,
and likewise, he would continue to write
within the censored language of French
to express his experience
under the occupation,
writing a poetic vision of exile.
Fondane is a particularly
interesting case for thinking
about how authors changed
their approaches to writing
and how they responded to
their position in France
under the occupation,
and I say that because he
revised most of his poetry;
much of it, already
published during the war.
And he left these revisions
behind with his wife,
who survived him,
and he reorganized his poems
into a collection called
"Le mal des fantomes,"
which could be translated
as "The Ache of Phantoms"
or maybe a play on words
of (speaks in French),
which means homesickness,
so maybe "Homesickness of Phantoms."
And it was first published in the '60s
and is only now really being
translated into English.
The multiple manuscript versions
of "Le mal des fantomes" are housed
at the archive Bibliotheque
litteraire Jacques Doucet
in Paris, and these archival
materials really bring to life
the way Fondane was questioning
and reworking his ideas
and thinking about exile, in particular.
And at this point,
I would like to focus
on one very long poem
that Fondant revised during the War,
"Ulysse," or "Ulysses."
And he began it in 1929
when he was in Argentina,
working on a surrealist film project,
but he finished and
published the poem in 1933.
"Already in the interwar
version of the poem,
Fondane creates a Jewish
Ulysses on a 20th-century voyage
to America," "to the Americas,"
actually, "and beyond,
always in exile."
And he's accompanied by immigrants
who are displaced after World War I
and in the wake of pogroms.
Fondane marked up the
1933 edition of "Ulysse,"
published by "Cahiers
du journal des poetes,"
making revisions in the 1940s by hand
on its published pages,
writing out new pages and
typing out new sheets of poems.
And this archival object
really shows the shifts
in his writing.
On the title page, he crossed
out the date of publication
and changed it to 1944.
He updated his list of published works.
He crossed out the name of the publisher.
And on a different page than from here
that I don't have an image of,
he creates his own invented press name
called "Edition sans fin,"
or "No-End Editions,"
as if to indicate that his
writing would be interrupted
or that he found no sense of completion.
As a Jewish emigre writer,
Fondane was now cut off
from literary life in occupied Paris
because it was illegal for him to publish.
In his unpublished afterword to "Ulysse,"
he explains his motivation
to rewrite his poetry in the 1940s,
and his current position in France
is at the heart of this decision:
"The second version of
'Ulysse,'" or "Ulysses,"
"is being shaped day by
day; it is not yet finished;
by a man who has just barely returned
from a prisoner-of-war
camp and from the hospital
and whom the police are
tracking at every intersection
to throw him in a concentration camp."
And he actually crosses out
"to throw him in a concentration camp,"
and this erasure of the
disclosure of his ultimate fear
or the ultimate fear of being
sent to a concentration camp
is a kind of self-censorship
on a note that would
never even be published,
and in fact, he wonders if
his poem will ever be finished
or if he'll be interrupted.
An afterword he typed up
for the final version of the
poem "Exode," "The Exodus,"
might further explain his situation.
He wrote that, although he
could not publish at the time,
books search for friends
rather than a public.
He ends it with a line that's often used
in resistance pamphlets,
which is he asks the
reader to take the trouble
to recopy or have recopied his text.
Since he could no longer publish openly
as he had done before the war,
Fondane creates his own
edition of his poem,
and I can show one
particularly telling change
that has been studied before,
especially by Monique Jutrin,
who's written a lot about Fondane.
In 1933, he has a line:
"a Jew naturally and yet Ulysses."
And then, he changed it in the '40s
to "a Jew, naturally,
you were a Jew, Ulysses."
And so Jewishness is
no longer a coincidence
but rather a natural part of the condition
of traveling and displacement.
Maybe in the few moments we have...
I'm sorry I'm a couple of minutes over,
but I wanted to look
at the poem "L'Exode."
And it's a long poem that's a
cycle of dramatic dialogues,
and he added a whole
section, during the war,
about the June 1940 defeat
and civilian flight.
The poem is about these cycles
of exile throughout history,
and he represents each with a river,
the Nile for Jewish enslavement in Egypt;
the rivers of Babylon,
or the shores of Babylon,
for the destruction of the Second Temple
and the exile from Jerusalem;
and finally, the Seine for
the June 1940 civilian flight.
And the poem takes its central
imagery from Psalm 1:37
about the lamentation of the Jewish people
after the siege of Jerusalem.
I won't read it, but this
repeats throughout the poem,
and by using the psalm,
Fondane assimilates the 1940 Exode
into a recurring history of exile.
And in so doing, he compares
the exile of the Jews
after the destruction of the
Second Temple in Jerusalem
to the Exodus from Paris
and a kind of destruction of a lost Zion
and a paradise for
Jewish immigrant authors.
There's another section
that makes this quite clear.
He transforms the famous
line from Psalm 1:37:
"If I forget you, oh Jerusalem."
He says, "We were leaving Paris behind us.
Ah, if ever I forget you, Jerusalem."
And Fondane also addresses
a linguistic pain associated with exile,
and that's forgetting your own language
and being displaced in a new language.
At the moment of leaving Paris/Jerusalem,
the speaker exclaims
that he gets on his knees
and sobs in this language
that he forgets but that he remembers.
And you see he has
transliterated Hebrew here,
and this is the words
from the Shema prayer,
the most fundamentally
important prayer for Jews,
a declaration of unity with God.
And so Hebrew here is
transliterated in the text,
and it's interesting to
note he makes a mistake,
actually, in the Hebrew,
and it's kind of this memory
of the prayer for him.
So throughout the poem, Fondane expresses
the complexity of losing
France after the defeat,
of losing his position in France,
a double loss of home,
as a Jewish immigrant and as a writer
'cause he's lost his position
as a writer in France,
or his ability to publish anymore.
I'll just come to a conclusion now
and say a little bit what
happened to these two writers.
Fondane was very tragically deported
to Auschwitz from Drancy
in 1944, and he died
just a few weeks after the
liberation of France that year.
His archives are, as I said, in Paris.
You can look at them in a room
that overlooks the Pantheon,
a secular temple to the great
men and women of France.
And there's actually a
plaque in the Pantheon
about writers who died in the war,
and his name is included.
And as I mentioned, Malaquais
was able to get to Mexico,
and he eventually came to America
and became an American citizen.
He had a Guggenheim Fellowship
and did a Ph.D. in comparative
literature, I believe.
So these two writers had
completely different paths and politics.
They didn't know each other,
but they fill a gap
in what Jewish writers were
thinking about and writing about
during the war itself.
I didn't have so much of a chance
to engage with Fondane's
multilingualism in his poetry,
but both authors were very interested
in French language and accent
and transliteration of other languages,
how to break down the barrier
between French and other languages.
They were both very
engaged with revisions.
As I said, Malaquais revised
his book just before his death,
so he was thinking about this
into the end of his life,
and Fondane revised his
poetry during the war.
I'm happy to continue the
conversation in Q and A,
and thank you so much.
- Julia, thank you.
That was such a double pleasure,
your sense of the material world,
both the materiality of language, words,
and also these amazing archival documents
that you put on the PowerPoint.
The postcard that he does a detournement,
recreates it as a literary
text, that's amazing.
I've never seen anything like that.
They're both very appealing characters.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I guess my first question
for you is about accents
'cause I think your
analysis is so powerful.
One of the things I was thinking,
looking at the representations
of the Jewish accent,
is there was a problem in occupied France,
which is that the Yiddish accent sounds
just like the German accent.
So presumably, all these Nazis
would also have made those same...
You woulda been imitated
exactly the same way
so that this French nationalism,
on the right,
had to embrace Naziism and still mock.
- And I wonder if that's the reason
why Rebatet refers to
it as Yiddish accents,
because, actually, most of
these people in the cafes,
they're not speaking Yiddish.
They're speaking German with
each other, a lot of them.
And so maybe that's why he has to make it
that they're speaking Yiddish,
that they can't be speaking German.
And Malaquais does funny things, too.
He shows that all of these refugees
have all kinds of different accents,
but he also shows that
the Germans have accents.
He also shows that there are
all these Persian French Jews
and they're confronting
the Southern French accent.
So he's showing how
everyone has an accent.
There isn't this native French accent.
- Well, yeah, I think there's
something very important
in what you're saying about...
We need to reconceive of accents.
You and I know that our field
was absolutely reactionary
on the question of accents.
There was only one way to speak French.
- [Julia] Yeah.
- And having the wrong
accent could deny you tenure.
I'm exaggerating, but there
was something about that,
and the other thing you
said I thought was very wise
was that, for the anti-Semites,
the question of accent,
there was only one kind of accent.
It meant that language was
completely predictable.
- Right, right, that it was just
racially defined somehow and
you were born a certain way.
- That it was like a template.
You'd either say it with
the G or the P or whatever,
or you'd say it in the right way.
- Right, right.
- And I guess what you're showing
about Malaquais and Fondane
is that they really made
language unpredictable
in every way.
- Yeah, thank you.
Yes, Fondane, in his poem,
also shows that there isn't just
this one monolingual language.
There are other parts of his poems
where he does all kinds of
interesting thing with language.
The speaker says, "He's
speaking my language,
but I don't understand it,"
or other people are speaking his language,
and he doesn't understand it.
And this breakdown of
what monolingualism is
as Derrida would do many years later.
But already, in his poems, I think,
he's trying to get away
from the idea of French
as this one monolingual language
with these barriers
that keep everyone out.
- French has gotten more
interesting, for sure.
I was struck
when you quoted the translations
from "Planete sans visa"
that they were using
English for the Yiddish
but just changing the spelling a little
to make it non-standard.
So in 1947 at Doubleday in New York,
they didn't wanna reproduce Yiddish words
in an English-language text?
- Well, actually-
- Did they in French?
Did they in the French?
- No, in French, also, he doesn't.
No, it's really interesting
because both he, Jean Malaquais,
and Romain Gary do this,
where they have characters...
It's just in French, but
you're meant to understand
that they're not speaking French,
and it's really interesting to think
about how they represent other languages.
And I don't know if it's that Malaquais...
Perhaps Malaquais really
wouldn't have fully been able
to write that in Yiddish.
And so it's interesting to
think about what it means.
This is something that
more-contemporary writers in France
have talked about,
writing in Yiddish in French.
Also, actually, a lot of
different contemporary writers
have talked about this
idea in America also.
- It's how you signify another language
within the language, I guess.
Isn't there an expression
like (speaks in French)
or (speaks in French)
being in a footnote?
- Yes, yes, yes, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, that's good.
- We have a few more minutes
if there are some questions.
If there aren't more questions,
you and I could go on talking forever.
(Julia chuckles)
Lemme ask you a question
really on behalf of one of our students.
who's starting to work on
Malaquais and Norman Mailer,
because that was a very
enabling friendship
for both of them really,
the American and this guy who had...
I guess it was Varian Fry
who got him to Mexico and to the U.S.
Is that who he got-
- Yeah, that's right.
- And what do you think
Norman Mailer learned
from Malaquais's multilingualism?
Certainly, we don't associate Mailer
with that kind of language play.
- Yeah, that's interesting;
I don't know if I have
a really good answer;
because Malaquais translated
a text by Norman Mailer.
But I have seen one film discussion
between the two authors,
and they were especially
talking about politics
because Malaquais...
I didn't have a chance
to really get into this,
but he was a very committed Trotskyist.
- Mexico was the right place for him.
(Alice laughs)
- Right, yeah. (laughs)
They were talking a lot
about that, and Malaquais
was saying how he never
compromised himself in any way
and he was very staunch in his support.
What stands out to me more
is their conversation
about politics, I must say,
but it is really interesting
to think about the
connection between these two.
- (indistinct) certainly think of Mailer
as a super New Yorker,
and we forget that he was ever...
I think he was in France
for a year, wasn't he,
on the G.I. Bill?
- Oh, yes, I think so, yeah.
I'm not so familiar.
- Yeah, I'm sorry, I'm taking
you away from your topic.
- No, no, not at all, but I
know that there are letters
with them figuring out places to stay
in France or vacation apartment in Paris.
(Alice laughs)
- That's (indistinct).
- It's such an unexpected connection,
Norman Mailer and Malaquais.
- Can I ask you a little
more about translation?
Malaquais translated himself?
- No, he-
- [Alice] Oh, Peter Grant translated-
- Peter Grant translated him,
but there was actually a different person
who was supposed to,
originally, translate him.
And there's a really
extensive correspondence
between him and this
translator, and you see
that Malaquais had a really
amazing grasp on English.
He was a really talented polyglot.
He knew many languages.
- So he must have been very
involved in the translation.
- He was, and it's interesting,
the things he specifies to the translator.
His archives are at
the Harry Ransom Center
and very accessible there.
- Oh, that's fantastic.
There's been all this work done recently
on the lives of translators
and on translator-author relationships,
and this sounds like,
really, a good archive
for people working on that.
- Definitely, it's a really
interesting correspondence,
yeah.
- Yeah, somebody's asking
if the conversation is going to be taped,
and I think Inessa said
that it was gonna be taped.
Lemme see what she's answering.
Yes, in a couple of weeks,
people will be able to
listen to Julia's lecture
on a recording,
which is great because there
was so much rich textual detail
and ways for us to go back
and reread these two writers.
So I just wanna thank you very much.
What a pleasure.
- Thank you so much
for the invitation. (chuckles)